en marchant dans le stationnement de
ceux-ci h et celle d alberto mirarchi
espèrent apercevoir sa mère à la fenêtre
l'interdiction de visites oblige il ne
l'a pas vue depuis dimanche
ça me cause beaucoup de peine ça fait
cinq sens je suis si tous les jours de
lundi à dimanche
le matin est ce que ce soit a su si tous
les jours je lai du la salle du lit je
le fais manger et l'affection physio
fait tout pour elle même son bain âgé de
87 ans marié poupaud ne comprend ni le
français ni l'anglais
elle souffre de démence écrit beaucoup
de m'adresser à françois legault de ce
peuple est si peu le cd prochaine
rentrée world leurs parents andré
latulippe 83 ans vit dans une résidence
privée de mont tremblant sa fille
johanne juge inadmissible de ne pas
pouvoir lui rendre visite pour vous
offrir des soins de base sont avait un
genre une forme de dérogation l'eau en
ce sens qu on pourrait écrire ou deux
jours
comme je vous dis en étant conscient
qu'il faut prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour pour contaminer
personnes ou a dit salem demeure dans un
6 h et celle des et constate la déprime
ambiante qui s'installe ce qui existe
ainsi que les préposés sont débordés
donc ils sont le regroupement québécois
des résidences pour aînés comprend que
les résidents aient besoin de leurs
proches mais les exceptions doivent être
réservées aux cas particuliers
et je parle de visites chez le médecin
je prends le nez qui doit sortir le pour
aller chez le dentiste par le conseil
pour la protection des malades est en
faveur de l'interdiction des visites
mais comprend aussi les familles nous on
va appuyer les gens qui vont demander à
pouvoir se rendre au chevet de leurs
proches
malgré le risque qu'on continue ou qu'on
augmente à nouveau pour celles et ceux
qu'on veut protéger malgré tout tous
espèrent des consignes claires de québec
pour gérer les cas d'exception ici
valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal